what compels you to start writing about
about the topic of retirement yeah thank
you for the question you know the big
thing for me was coaching people I was
sitting with people everyday people
kneecap to kneecap helping them with
their money I've been a part of Dave
Ramsey's team for thirteen years now and
you know really talking to people
everyone was making some assumptions
every people were thinking that Social
Security was going to be enough to save
the day they thought that that would
they didn't have to worry about doing
anything that Social Security would take
care of them and then I would hear
people saying well when I get to age 65
or when I get to 70 and I kept looking
and I kept hearing these myths over and
over again and then ice like someone's
got to do something like someone needs
to tell people that retirements not an
age it's a financial number someone
needs to tell people that Social
Security won't be enough for you to live
your dream and so I kept saying this
over and over and then I was in you know
curling my hair one day right haha
ashamed people don't laugh I'm bald by
choice I can grow all the hair I want in
this section right here but anyway but I
kept thinking someone needs to do
something I realized you know what I
needed to be that somebody I wanted to
try to help yeah so what were some of
those myths that you came across I mean
we often think that like there was two
things that I encountered I used to
manage a large group of people at one
point I was a director of operations for
150 retail stores and one of the things
I know that I did right because I did a
lot of things wrong is I started saving
for retirement early now I didn't start
saving enough but I started saving
earlier just kicking some money into a
401k and I helped other people sign up
for those 401k accounts as soon as they
were on-boarded with with our company
and in in doing that I saw a couple
excuses one excuse was I'm too old to
start saving for retirement which sounds
crazy to me and the other excuse which
was even crazier was I'm too young I'll
get to that someday where those some of
the excuses that you came across those
are two of the biggest ones that I would
hear people would think it was too late
for them because they didn't get started
early and so baby boomers
on down the line and I kept explained to
him no no you still have an opportunity
to do something you've got an
opportunity to make new decisions today
that will impact your dreams and young
people telling them you know they say
well Chris you know at retirement says
for old people and I'd say it's not an
age it's a financial number so getting
them to understand your money has to
best friends time and compound interest
if your money gets to sit there on a
401k or 403b
with time and compound interest that
money will earn more money down the road
so if I can get young people started
right and get people that are a little
bit older to realize it's not too late
what you have is people are still able
to chase their dreams
people are still able to have options
for themselves and that's what I want
ultimately I want people doing the
things they want to do not waking up to
wake work another 12 to 14 hour shift on
the job they don't love
you